good morning I hope everyone's had a
chance to get a cup of tea a cup of
coffee something to eat whatever you
need to get this wonderful morning
jump-started and very grateful to the
weather gods for having given us such a
perfect day for a conference so that we
can all huddle together in this room for
the next day and a half and pity
everybody who has to be out in this
weather my name is Johnny Buckley and
I'm the director of the South Asia
Institute and it is my very great
pleasure to welcome you all to cast in
contemporary India a conference in
commemoration of one of Columbia
University's most famous and eminent
alumni dr. Bhimrao Ramji Ambedkar
we're all familiar with Ambedkar is the
drafter of the Indian Constitution and
the leader of the movement in India
against untouchability and caste ISM yet
more than 50 years after Indian
independence caste prejudice caste
atrocities caste discrimination caste
based oppression remained deeply
entrenched features of Indian political
life our 4 conference panels are all
concerned with contemporary India
contemporary India and the panelists
will address and discuss Ambedkar's
legacy as it has manifested itself in
the law of modern India in the gendered
character of caste relations in
electoral and other politics and in
religious conversions away from Hinduism
I will leave it to the panels and the
panelists to discuss these issues and at
the risk of sounding like an NPR station
I need to acknowledge the sources of
additional funding for this program and
let you know as well that our fall
fundraiser the conference tomorrow
afternoon but speaking seriously the
Institute simply could not have
organized this conference by itself let
alone bring seven scholars from
different locations in India to New York
without a little bit of help and I'd
like to thank our co-sponsors beginning
with the Institute for religion culture
and public life the first of our
co-sponsors to sign on and I'd like to
extend
the hearty voter gratitude to Al Stepan
for being so encouraging both in Word
and in deed for this conference as well
as thank his co-director Mark Taylor who
I hope we will see a little later today
I'd also like to note that the Center
for Human Rights documentation and
research a virtual documentation
exhibition of documents created by South
Asia bibliography Bindu part is posted
on the website of the South Asia
collection of the Columbia library the
center was instrumental in providing the
services that allow us to document the
conference as a digital recording which
will be available through Columbia
University's website and I thank Pamela
Graham area studies librarian for
helping to negotiate that digital
recording I'd also like to thank the
Center for the study of ethnicity and
race and the director Francis Negron
Montaner who will be with us later this
evening and Sudhir Venkatesh who is the
director of the Institute for social and
economic research and policy the
Department of vittle Eastern South Asian
and African Studies was also forthcoming
with their help in the chair should the
toka Viraj not only gave us funding but
will introduce our closing plenary
speaker tomorrow
Gopal guru the Provost office in
particular the past Provost Alan
Brinkley and the current Provost Claude
Steele have also been very helpful in
allowing us to bring some scholars over
from India Raj Campbell a and the
Ambedkar international mission of North
America have been consistent in their
encouragement to me to pull together a
conference like this and I'm very
grateful for his help
Lenny Gordon and the tarkna das
foundation made it possible for us to
invite Gopal guru to be our first-ever
taraknath das visiting professor at the
South Asia Institute and he will be with
us for two weeks starting today we're
also very grateful to Columbia
University President Lee Bollinger whose
schedule as you might imagine is very
full and yet he's taken time out on a
blustery Friday morning to come to speak
to us about affirmative action
and the comparison with caste and
reservations I'm very grateful to him
for doing that as well as Nick Dux
Christophe jafra lo Anupama Rao garu
Vishwanath and Thomas Hanson for
agreeing to serve as panel moderators
and introducers before I turn things
over to Nick Dux for the first panel
there are a few announcements I need to
make barring the panelists there is no
food or drink allowed in this room
except for water bottles this is at the
insistence of the building management
and I thank you all for your cooperation
I've also been asked to let you all know
that while there is a coat-check outside
and you can leave your belongings there
please keep valuables with you at all
times
secondly while I'm concluding this
welcome do please take a second to turn
off your cell phones or move them to
vibrate or quiet mode or whatever it is
so that the panel is not disturbed by
ringtones and so on our program on
Friday today will have three panels the
first which should have started at nine
o'clock but in wonderful South Asian
time it will begin perhaps five minutes
later than planned but the first panel
of nine o'clock the second at 11:15 and
the third at 2:15 we will have breaks
for coffee and lunch coffee is available
coffee tea is available outside
throughout the day and all of tomorrow
so please feel free if you need to take
a break to get coffee outside we just
ask that you don't bring it inside
no lunch will be provided today but we
are inviting all of you to please stay
after yong-pan days plenary address for
a reception at 5:45 the reception will
be outside in the foyer and we'd like to
invite all of you to join us at that
reception and an informal conversation
with all of the panelists tomorrow
Saturday there'll be a morning panel at
9:15 I apologize for the earliness of
the panel but such as academic life we
have to start early in the morning and
we will have a closing plenary address
by our taraknath das visiting professor
guru at 11:30 in the spirit of keeping
the South Asian Institute South Asian
and not merely Indian we've organized
the sri lankan lunch tomorrow please
join us for that lunch at 1:00 p.m. in
the lobby if it gets too crowded in the
lobby we have additional seating in
rooms 15 10 and 15 twelve one last
announcement before I turn this over to
Nick Dirk's there are ten of us wearing
11 of us now with my student Christopher
from my undergraduate class Gandhi's
India who volunteered as well as Rashida
who volunteered to come and help out
with this conference so there will be 12
of us wearing blue nametags Columbia
blue nametags if you have any questions
about the conference about the schedule
or where to find the best food in the
neighborhood please feel free to ask and
without further ado I'd like to invite
Nicholas Dirk's
the moderator of the first panel to come
up here to introduce the first panel and
the panelists and president Bollinger
thank you very much and at the risk of
conflict of interest I am going to
include in the list of thanks thanks to
the director of the southern Asian
Institute John Keeble a professor of
history who has worked tirelessly and I
can attest to that to organize this
event and has been doing so over the
course of some months so I'm delighted
to recognize her role this is a
conference to examine the place of caste
in contemporary India but it is also to
celebrate the connection of BR Ambedkar
to to Columbia University it is here
that Ambedkar studied and earned a PhD
in political science even closer to home
for me it is here that Ambedkar wrote
his first paper on this on the caste
system delivering it in trans Boaz is
famous anthropology seminar in 1916
and which he argued that a combination
of the social logic of endogenous
exclusion and the role of prestige
attached to the Brahmin in Hindu
religion combined to produce the
extraordinary durability and hold of the
caste system and it is here at Columbia
that Ambedkar began his study of the
political character and effects of
different kinds of political
institutions including the Constitution
or at least other constitutions than
India's he would go on of course to play
a major role in that although I bet card
went on from Columbia to do his formal
legal training at the London School of
Economics
we like to claim a very special role for
Columbia in the conception and drafting
of the Indian Constitution which bans
discrimination based on untouchability
and enshrines a number of critical
principles framing provisions for
reservations or reserve seats in
education and government employment for
historically oppressed groups classified
of course on the basis of the
sociological categories of caste and
tribe as a university we take great
pride in our connection to embed carp in
the extraordinary accomplishments of his
life fighting against injustice and in
his lifelong commitment to finding and
using political and legal means to
redress the social and cultural legacies
of oppression and discrimination for br
ambedkar caste was the principal
impediment to social justice equality
and reform in India but caste for him
was not just a civil institution for it
was inseparable from the beliefs and
institutions of Hinduism more generally
despite this latter concern one that
stayed with him throughout his life and
led ultimately for him to him led
ultimately to lead him to convert to
Buddhism just the year before he died he
was both a social activist and a
constitutional lawyer he led marches and
demonstrations wrote tracts and gave
speeches while also making perhaps his
most enduring mark through his role as
principal architect of the Indian
Constitution convinced as he was that
Untouchables could only thrive through
constitutional guarantees for
non-discrimination
and reservations and educational
opportunity employment and political
representation born in 1891 into a
Maharashtrian mehar then called
untouchable family imbed car studied in
army containments and then in bombay
graduating from elphinston college in
bombay in 1912 his educational
attainment in social and and and social
distinction gained the recognition of
the Maharaja Gaikwad of Baroda who gave
him a scholarship for travel here to New
York to Columbia where he studied
towards his PhD as I said in political
science he only actually received his
degree in 1927 but he was here in the
years just before and at the outbreak of
World War one after returning from
London where he also did his legal work
at the LSE he returned to practice as a
lawyer and Baroda finding that despite
his educational attainments and
accomplishments he was unable to rent
rooms in town and he was the victim of
continual insults having to do with his
caste status so he moved to Bombay where
he became a college lecturer and a
practitioner before the Bombay High
Court in 1927 he was officially
nominated to the Legislative Council as
one of the two representatives of the
depressed classes during the next two
decades he maintained a role as a
prominent figure in official circles as
well as in government at the same time
that he took up a series of political
and social struggles on behalf of his
fellow again I say Untouchables but of
course we know Sayed uhlet's including
the cause of educational access the work
towards abolishing traditional village
duties campaign various campaigns to
gain access to public water and of
course repeated movements for temple
access for doublet groups Ambedkar also
mounted several dramatic symbolic
assaults on Hindu scriptures
illustrating his sense that since caste
was so integral to Hinduism the religion
itself had to be questioned and deeply
scrutinized even as embed car took
Gandhi on over the question of whether
religion and caste could be detached
from each other he famously dueled with
Gandhi
over separate electorates for
untouchables the quarrel took on epic
proportion in 1932 when Gandhi announced
too fast unto death over the
establishment by Ramsay MacDonald of a
separate electorate for untouchables in
large part as a consequence of
Ambedkar's advocacy of depressed classes
interests at the roundtable conference
Gandhi was opposed to separate electrics
for any group he grudgingly accepted
them for Muslims for Christians for
Sikhs and for and anglo-indians but drew
the line when it came to dots the
communal award of August 17 1932 granted
do--let's embed Kars demand for separate
electorates in areas of their largest
concentration and that is what led to
the fast Ambedkar ultimately had to give
in to Gandhi's plea although they worked
out a compromise known as the poun
impact in which the electorate was
maintained as joint while the numbers of
seats specifically reserved for
untouchable groups was doubled and this
was a huge rupture in the history of
Indian nationalism and it continues in
some sense to underwrite and carry on
with later debates over how to think
about the nature of the Dalek community
visa vie the Hindu majority throughout
his life Ambedkar oscillated between
legal and political advocacy for the
role of depressed classes in Indian
society and symbolic protests against
the deep stigmatize a stigmatization
produced by caste and its core
relationship to Hinduism itself his
concern about incorporation into the
Hindu fold put him in conflict with many
Hindu leaders claiming Untouchables as
part of the Indian Hindu majority a
claim he decisively rejected when he
converted to Buddhism and indeed
advocated the mass conversion to
Buddhism of all Tollett groups in his
role in drafting and framing the Indian
Constitution Ambedkar successfully
advocated for a policy of compensatory
discrimination a very strong form of
affirmative action for the Scheduled
Castes is that these are the dalek
groups that had been denominated by the
government as scheduled put on a
particular schedule and tribal groups as
well called the Scheduled Tribes and
Constitution declared and embed car
played a great role in the framing of
these words I'll quote the state shall
promote with special care the
educational and economic interests of
the weaker sections of the people and in
particular the Scheduled Castes and
Scheduled Tribes and shall protect them
from social injustice and all forms of
exploitation and a quote the
Constitution's ban on discrimination and
government employment explicitly permit
permits the state to go on to make
though in addition to this and I quote
again any provision for the reservation
of appointments or posts in favor of any
backward class of citizens which in the
opinion of the state is not adequately
represented in the services under this
day end of quote and in particular in
regard to efforts not just to ban
discrimination but to counter its
legacies and its continuing effects the
Constitution further stipulated that the
discrimination Clause specifically shall
not I quote prevent the state from
making any special provision for the
advancement of any socially and
educationally backward classes of
citizens or for the Scheduled Castes and
Scheduled Tribes
end of quote provisions banning
discrimination and declaring the
principle of individual equality thus
had to sit side by side with provisions
that made clear not only that special
provisions be made but that they be made
through the use of reservations the
Constitution initially dictated
reservations that in effect set aside
roughly 22% of seats and government
employment legislative positions and
educational institutions for Scheduled
Tribes and castes well it framed the
hope that such reservations would not be
necessary in perpetuity it also allowed
for their continuation up to a maximum
of 50% now as we are having this
conference here at Columbia indeed one
of the most distinguished among American
universities but also one that has
struggled like many of our peers with
the legacies of our own countries and in
this case of our city's history it is I
think fitting that we begin our
examination of the history and
consequences of affirmative action in
India with specific reference to the
history and current condition of
affirmative action here in the US and
especially
in US universities it is therefore
especially fitting that we do so given
the role of the president of Columbia
University Lee Bollinger in framing the
contemporary debate over affirmative
action one of the nation's leading
scholars of First Amendment issues he
has taught and written on freedom of
speech and the press for over thirty
years and has a book in fact a new book
on the place of the press and a new
global and of course new economic
environment coming out just in a few
months I think but in addition to his
work as a scholar on First Amendment
issues freedom of the press and the like
he was also the name defendant in the
twin 2003 Supreme Court cases that
clarified and upheld affirmative action
in higher education and president
Bollinger became in part through that a
national advocate for diversity and for
integration in recognition of his
leadership on these issues he received
the National Humanitarian Award from the
National Conference for community and
justice and the National equal justice
award from the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense and education fund among many
other honors including the Clark Kerr
award which is the highest honor
conferred by the Faculty of the
University of California for his service
to higher education especially in
matters relating both to freedom of
speech and diversity president Bollinger
is a fellow of the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences in the American
Philosophical Society and prior to
coming to Columbia served as the
president of the University of Michigan
where he was also Dean of the law school
and a law professor now this panel for
me is a personal pleasure and a bit of a
reminder of the first time I ever met
Lee Bollinger which was at the
University of Michigan in 1996 shortly
before I was to move to Columbia where I
gave a paper on the aftermath of the
Mundell commission's report and the
controversy surrounding questions having
to do with reservations in the 1990s and
president Bollinger took time out of his
busy schedule then to come and listen to
the paper and then and now I should have
known better asked me the hardest
questions I got all evening in the
seminar that ensued but he made me think
deeply at that point about the
similarities as well as the differences
of the Indian and American
variances and made me also feel the need
for the kinds of things that we do in
area studies context to be brought out
and moved into conversation with and
comparison against other cases but of
course in some ways chief among them the
case within which we live which is to
say in this case the case of the
struggle over affirmative action in the
United States whether dealing with the
historical legacies of slavery and
racial discrimination or caste
oppression and caste based forms of
discrimination it is inescapable that
these two great democracies India and
the United States have struggled to
enshrine principles of individual
equality while also seeking to address
the tremendous historical and
sociological impediments to equality
that continued to the present day but
these two countries have done so very
differently even though histories of
caste and race of untouchability and
slavery share so much in common
differences intensified in the u.s. case
around the famous Bucky case of 1978
when justice Powell made his declaration
about the value of diversity for all not
just for oppressed groups president
Bollinger himself defended the
University of Michigan's admission
policies around principles of diversity
not by defending quotas or reservations
and of course the outcome of greater and
Gratz
short lived though they might have been
in Michigan itself for reasons that
perhaps will go into was one that put
further restrictions on a system that
might look in any instance like it was
using quantitative rather than
qualitative measures president Bollinger
is joined in this panel by two scholars
and we could not be luckier to have the
assembled group here this morning mark
Galanter who has been for many years
professor of law and South Asian Studies
at the University of Wisconsin wrote
perhaps the seminal work on the history
of compensatory discrimination in India
a book entitled competing equalities law
and the Backward Classes in India it's
also written law and society in modern
India along with many many other essays
and works relating to some of the issues
that we're addressing today and we're
delighted that he drove in from Madison
to join us at our
and Pratap Bhanu Mehta who is the
president of the Center for Policy
Research in New Delhi and also the
author of burden of democracy co-editor
of a work entitled public institutions
in India performance in design and hard
at work on a major study of the Indian
Supreme Court extended his stay at NYU
in order to be with us this morning
before he flies back to Delhi and his
role in the center there this evening so
the format that we're going to follow
this morning will be I'm going to ask
president Bollinger to begin by framing
the case of affirmative action and some
of the issues that would most parallel
the kinds of discussions we're having
visa be the case of India to start
things off I will then ask professor
Galanter to say a little bit about the
history of legislation and
constitutional debate around issues of
affirmative action and compensatory
discrimination and then I will ask
professor Mehta to say a bit about more
recent debates within India as well as
the contemporary context and environment
for thinking about issues relating to
affirmative action in particular visa
vie questions around educational
institutions after we hear from each of
them we'll start a conversation among us
and then we'll move into taking
questions and comments from all of you
and we'll shoot to be done at 10:45 as
per our instructions thank you
so please join me in thanking Lee
Bollinger for coming to join us Johnny
this is a tremendous thing to do for the
University and more broadly and
delighted to be part of it the panel I
couldn't be happier
having the prospect of being able to
listen to what they have to say this is
really about India not about the United
States but I need to learn more and I'm
I'm looking forward to learning more
what I will do is simply outline very
quickly my sort of interpretation of
affirmative action in the United States
which I think falls into nicely into
three parts
and then of course leave it open to any
kind of comparisons that we can draw I
would say just this by way of opening I
think we all understand how comparative
work is very very important but it does
seem to me that it's important to take
the next step and that is we're in the
process of creating it seems to me a
kind of global society and even though
it's still very much individual nation
states and all that comes with that and
even though they're very weak
international institutions for governing
the world the fact of the matter is the
way the world is evolving especially
through capitalism and free markets and
becoming more and more interdependent
that the course of the next several
decades will be to create the kind of
institutions that will be needed to to
deal with that world that more
integrated world the most recent move
from a g7 to a g20 is I think just one
among many steps along that path and the
point is that affirmative action the
concept the effort the need for it will
be something that we will face globally
as well as interestingly in individual
nation states so I think it has that
this kind of meeting this kind of
discussion has that extremely important
sort of forward-looking role there's
great variation in this room I know many
of the faces here great variation in the
degree of knowledge I assume about the
u.s. affirmative action issues so I'll
try to be both respectful of those who
know just about as much as anyone and
those who for whom this is a fresh
subject as I said I think it really
falls into three sort of periods in the
first period is 1954 to the let's say
1970 I think then it's 1970 until the
cases that Nick referred to the Grutter
case the gratz case gritter case again
gratz case which came out at the
University of Michigan in which I was a
named defendant and the person most
responsible for sort of leading the
defense of affirmative action and and I
think it's from that so it's 1970 until
that case in 1997 or 2003 which is when
the supreme court rendered its opinions
and then we're in that third period now
the first period is really Brown versus
Board of Education the Brown versus
Board of Education declared that
official segregation and discrimination
on the basis of race was a violation of
a fundamental norm enshrined in the
Fourteenth Amendment to the United State
Constitution and could no longer stand
there's a lot of argument about whether
this would have happened if the Supreme
Court had not taken this step which it
did unanimously would the Society have
come to the same judgment that this was
a violation of fundamental values my own
view with these things are hard to
determine my own view is that it would
not have happened but for being in the
Constitution and for an independent
judiciary that could point to this as a
basic inconsistency between the ideals
of the society and the underlying
practice of invidious discrimination on
the basis of race Brown said in motion
for the next 20 years an effort not only
to end discrimination and segregation
but to achieve integration that too is
the debate within American society but
it's a very very important I think step
in our thinking it would not be
sufficient to think about simply ending
discrimination there was too much that
had happened over the preceding two
centuries that had to be overcome and
this was not just a matter of law it was
a matter of hearts and minds and so the
society had a major effort to try to
achieve integration the busing cases
were prime examples of this so for the
next again 20 years in the specific area
of public education the country
undertook effort after effort to find
ways to take children from different
schools that had formerly been
segregated and to integrate them and
busing was the way to do it
this became a lightning rod for many in
the society
it was a an effort to transform the way
in which the society was was
fundamentally structured turned out not
only in just having separate schools but
having separate housing patterns in
separate places to work and live
so that busing became the highly
controversial the other point to realize
about this period is that it was deeply
deeply rooted in a sense of centuries of
injustice that the society really had
harmed in the most serious ways a group
and groups Native Americans Hispanics
and most especially perhaps most visibly
because of the Brown case
african-americans had actively injured
populations within the society and this
had to be corrected that became not only
an organizing principle for how to deal
with race and ethnicity in American
society but it became an organizing
principle for almost every area of life
in the society and by that I mean if you
look at the First Amendment cases which
I teach and write about and so on many
of those prime cases were about race
they were about civil rights brown our
New York Times versus Sullivan is is
that to its core we think of that is a
great press freedom you can't hold a
newspaper press libel for false
statements of fact that hurts somebody's
reputation unless you can prove actual
malice well that case arose out of a New
York Times edition with the civil rights
ad twenty three copies arm I'm sorry few
hundred copies distributed in Alabama
about trying to raise money for civil
rights and that was an Alabama jury that
that brought that judgment against the
New York Times
the Supreme Court said no it was as much
about race as it was about about free
speech and you can go to criminal
justice you can go all across the the
Society and you can find the effects of
the efforts to overcome the history of
racial prejudice and discrimination in
the society reshaping American life the
second period I would describe as going
from about 1970 early 70s until the
until the 2003 Supreme Court cases what
defines that that's that's really when
affirmative action comes into play and
it really comes into effect in
universities universities were very much
behind the civil rights movement they
were the origins of lots of ideas and
and protests and and public action but
they so they were unanimous basically in
wanting this value and when it came time
to introduce affirmative action that's
the place where I think it was most
willingly embraced and it was done
almost out of frustration that is that
busing efforts the the tremendous
efforts of the Society for the twenty
years following Brown versus Board of
Education had not really produced what
people had expected and so affirmative
action was meant to integrate the
society there must be judges who are
African American there must be lawyers
there must be doctors there must be
business people there must be media
people I mean the sense was this society
will only deal with these problems when
there is true integration and
affirmative action is critical to that
the Bakke case that that Nick referred
to is in the late 70s and what happened
was that define this period just thirty
year period was the effort to normalize
affirmative action in American society
and by that I mean while the first
period was to link it to the roots
of the Society's past the second period
was to disconnect it from the past and
to make it seem as if this were just a
normal kind of American life and the
famous opinion of Justice Powell in the
Bakke case upholding affirmative action
in higher education really made this
point without ever saying that that's
what was happening what Powell said was
if you're a university and you have
affirmative action we will let you do it
but only if you say that it is for
diversity purposes for educational value
and not if you say is try to it's an
attempt to correct for past injustice
--is in the society so when I was Dean
of the law school of Michigan and 1987
and I were defending affirmative action
I could never ever say that the reason
why we do this is because there are 200
years of history of slavery and
discrimination so on and this society
has to overcome it and we as an
institution are prepared to to do that
we could never say it because there
would be a lawsuit instantly and it
would be declared unconstitutional so I
interpret that and all that happened as
an effort to normalize disconnect from
its past
what affirmative action was all about
when I became president in Michigan in
97 I heard immediately that we were
going to be sued by the conservative
group that was bringing lawsuits around
the country they've been very successful
they had won against the University of
Texas law school there had been a
movement in California prop 209 which
had passed ending affirmative action and
we were next we had to decide whether I
had to decide whether to defend this and
take it on or whether to give in at that
moment in 1997-98 it was overwhelmingly
unpopular to defend affirmative acts
it was not a really persuasive position
we decided to take it on and for the
next five years six years this was just
a major undertaking I won't go through
the cases that the point I want to make
is that my view was the only way this
could win was to do both things that had
happened in the first two periods permit
of action had to be connected back to
its roots that this was an effort and it
was still needed in order to overcome
centuries of discrimination and the
society had this task and it would only
happen in several generations we wish it
would happen sooner but it wasn't and
the second thing was that we had to
normalize it and say it was part of
diversity and those two really
interacted the only reason diversity
matters education is because of the
history and the effort to distinguish
them was was a mistake but we had to
make both arguments I made a decision
that I would never refer to Bakke I
would always refer to brown I would
never and and the other point was we had
to make this something that was
pervasive in American society you
unravel this and you're back to before
brown because every institution in the
society had embraced this and that's
where we got the military brief that was
so well known as saying if you tell
universities they can't have affirmative
action then the military will not be
able to have affirmative action and if
they can't have affirmative action which
they practice they will not have an
officer corps that is integrated to deal
with the military that just showed how
pervasive in American society this was
and fortunately the decision came down
in 2003 five to four very narrow I was
really Sandra Day O'Connor was the
crucial vote that it could continue and
it embraced both
rationales of history and diversity and
then did the final thing which I think
was odd and yet there it is that's the
world we're living in put a cap a time
cap on this a limit of 25 years it was
an odd thing for the Supreme Court never
does that I mean it never says you can
do this as a constitutional matter but
you can only do it for X period of years
and it's an interesting feature of where
we are at the moment there is a kind of
of lapse in the in the historical
process and we'll see where it goes from
there so that's my take on American
affirmative action and I very much look
forward to hearing how it works in India
Thanks
thank you very much I'm very pleased to
be here I just want to make a few points
in terms of the background of what some
of us called compensatory discrimination
in India as in the description of the
beneficiary groups there's all kinds of
terminological questions about what you
should call this policy in fact the name
compensatory discrimination did hasn't
really caught on most people just say
reservations which is the typical device
basically we're talking about reserved
seats quotas the typical device used in
India and both educational and settings
and in government jobs as well those are
the two central programs there's also
reservations of seats in parliament
these are the descendants of the Pune
pact that that Nik referred to come to
that in a minute versus a stepping back
even a little further wanna just say
that the whole notion of caste
subordination and hierarchy is a problem
to be solved of course is something that
has from time to time surfaced in India
historically but really moves into the
political realm first in the in the
intermittently in the 19th century with
jodi rell fool a and at the turn of the
century beginning of the 20th century
with some progressive
princes and it's and with that in the
early 20th century I think for the for
the first time or at least for the first
time in connection with with with
political arrangements the low castes
throughout India are envisioned as an
India wide stratum the term at the time
was the depressed classes which doesn't
exactly correspond to the group that has
emerged now as a deletes but it's pretty
close and in the maneuvered early 20th
century with the anticipation of more
Indian political participation and an
eventual control
there was this dispute about who is the
representative who says the who speaks
for this depressed stratum and Nicholas
said a little bit about the conflict
between Gandhi and dr. Ambedkar on this
and what what the eventual compromise
that he mentioned was one where seats
were in in the in these legislatures
were reserved for the then Untouchables
who were then got a new name Scheduled
Castes because they were listed in a
schedule at the end of the Government of
India act of 1936
so they got reserved seats only members
of these groups were eligible to run for
the seats but these were not separate
electorates
they called joint electorates
reservations only these people can stand
fur for office but everybody votes the
the original compromise included a
provision for kind of primary elections
in which only the members of the shared
request would would vote but those drop
by the wayside they were just never
never implemented turned out to be
expensive and and it just failed by the
way so but as part of the government of
India 1936 the question was we're going
to compile an official definitive list
of this of the groups that make up this
depressed stratum that's going to get
special representation in Parliament
it wasn't Parliament then it was the
various state legislature legislatures
of the various units of British India
now so commission went around to to
compile lists of these sheriff castes
and there were some uncertainty as to
who was included because in spite of
this being envisioned as an all-india
stratum there really were significant
differences from place to place in in
the what the caste hierarchies were like
and what the various practices were and
how definitely this the bottom stratum
so to speak was was delimited and
and visibly distinct but we have to make
a list you in the with a list and so the
list was there after at the time of
Independence just ten years after this
there with with a very different
political setting of the provisions for
special treatment for for the shadow
casts and the shadow tribes were put
into the Constitution and so this is
1950 and now we have a definite
authorization for special treatment for
these groups as a qualification to the
non-discrimination provisions of the
Constitution but one there's one
complication and here we have to sort of
circle back a little bit because in the
early 19th in the early 20th century
while the there were moves to to
ameliorate the condition and eventually
to define and these the depressed
classes shed Jocasta stratum there were
other groups mostly a bit higher on the
in the caste hierarchy which we've come
to call the backward classes now
sometimes the term back requesters is
used to include the Scheduled Castes and
tribes but so too sometimes the term is
use Other Backward Classes or OB sees as
this stratum above in traditional
thinking above the Scheduled Caste and
you'll notice that the provisions in the
Constitution for specialty because those
groups tended in some regions
particularly in the south
India a little bit in the west of India
to have successfully seized a chunk of
power in the local in local politics and
and had instituted reservations in jobs
and in education for themselves
sometimes including some provision for
the for the lowest strata as well so in
large parts of India the there were
already reservations for these backward
classes the Constitution wouldn't read
the debates in the Constitution the a
lot of people particularly from North
India didn't quite understand these
provisions and people from the South
were kind of reassuring and said yes yet
we've got all these and so the
terminology put in for special treatment
in the Constitution was sufficiently
inclusive as to basically endorse and
legitimate these local arrangements for
the OBCs as well as creating these new
as well as giving the basis for a set of
new preferential treatment for the
Scheduled Castes and Scheduled Tribes
and this this ambiguity about just who
the beneficiaries are is has sort of
been one of the defining characteristics
of what what's been going on in India
for the last sixty years so the
Constitution does provide for
reservations for these
favor castes in government jobs and
higher education there's a lot of other
little preferences but those are the
really important ones but then the
question is well just what is this route
the backward classes which includes
sheduled castes and tribes but what is
and who's gonna define it because
remember the Scheduled Castes and
Scheduled Tribes though definition the
list of those peoples just carried over
from the government of india from 1936
put in the constitution but who are the
backward classes and the constitution
makers punted they just said well we're
gonna set up a commission and this
commission will definitively decide the
commission came back in 1955 with a very
expansive definition who the back
professors were about 80% of the
population of India and the government
the government of the time a strongly
entrenched Congress government with a
very solid supermajority just brushed it
aside and decided not to implement it at
all and so and the question was kind of
laid to rest for the next 20 years and
at that time and I remember sort of
trying to do some research on this and
people said why are you researching this
whole question of the backward classes
and caste and that that's all you know
it's on its way out find a better topic
and they said there's India's moving
toward a cashless and classless society
that was the mantra of the time and so
in the meanwhile the South had sort of
retained at the state level various
kinds of benefits for the backward
classes the backward classes movement
in the northern states pretty much
pretty much it was pretty much defunct
until the great break-in sort of in the
history of independent India the
emergency of 1975 77 when which brought
into power temporarily a coalition
government the first real alternative to
the Congress and that coalition
government said in order to to try and
build political support said we should
have a second Backward Classes
permission to go out and find out who
these people really are the second
Backward Classes commission known as the
Mundel commission and prep is going to
talk about that so he's going to pick up
the story at that point well I'd say
that that the the with that suddenly
this regime of preferential programs for
Shengo castes and tribes was suddenly
expanded and now that there were a lot
of new preferential treatments at the
center eventually coming for these
middle groups so to speak so that the
provisions the original affirmative
action for the for the lowest and the
say marginalized groups the Scheduled
Castes and the sugar tribes were now
unfolded in a much larger program of
preferential treatment and
the the this the commission that the
Mondale Commission came in taking a very
expansive view who the beneficiaries
could be and so what we've had since
then is is this enlarged notion of
affirmative action or that's the direct
discrimination enlarge because now in
various ways about seventy percent of
the whole population is eligible for for
some level of benefits the judiciary has
basically the all the political parties
competing them now decided to be on the
side of this affirmative action there's
no real political dissent there's some
kind of social groups are the same
permit the judges in the Supreme Court
and after as the Indian Supreme Court is
is the is an arbiter of what the
Constitution is kind of unparalleled
power much more powerful in some ways
than the US Supreme Court in the sense
that one even though it has the terms of
the justices are rather short because of
the foot of compulsory retirement
nevertheless the judges basically
control appointments to their court at
this point this is a rather new
development last twenty years and so
that the court basically controls its
own membership and it has asserted that
it has the right to not only to
determine what the Constitution the
present text of the Constitution means
like iron us agree with us but they say
also though the amendment process is
rather easy in Parliament you keep
throwing up amendments and eat it just
just takes the two-thirds majority in
parliament but the court says we are the
judge of whether the amendments fit the
basic structure of the Constitution and
it's only amendments that comply with a
basic structure that will become valid
parts of the Constitution which we will
then interpret so so we have this this
very interesting kind of institutional
divide between the judiciary which has
been the cautious and limiting
institution as far as this affirmative
action goes and Parliament and
legislators which at this point then
have been they've been the accelerator
and the the courts that have been been
the brakes but the courts have been much
more restrictive in policing the
benefits for the other backward classes
and the courts have basically said you
can have all the provisions you like for
the shadow tests in charge of tribes but
much more limited preferential treatment
for the OBCs and the kind of signature
question here is what's called the
question of the creamy layer what the
what the courts have said is yes you can
make provision for these other backward
classes and those are basically kind of
middle I mean if there's a big range
from people down almost at the bottom to
people almost at the top and so they say
when we have these provisions you have
to eliminate the very well-off people
within the Backward Classes the
so-called creamy layer we don't want
people who sort of arrived already and
have high government jobs and have lots
of money
to be able to perpetuate their they can
perpetuate their their good fortune but
we're not going to help them with
special preferential treatment so so
each state is obliged to take the most
successful groups within its it's
backward classes and basically take them
out of the running this has caused great
perturbation of the the power that the
rest of the political universe in India
does not like this so there's a real
tension between the courts and the
legislators was I saved it as as
accelerators or breaks on this on the
administration of affirmative action I'm
gonna so this is kind of the broad
setting and I will let
in the interests of time and to be brief
I won't sort of take you through a kind
of blow-by-blow account of development
sports Mandela mean I think most of you
are familiar with the basic architecture
of the reservation regime as it's called
I think mark has laid out its elements
no technically it's capped at 50% this
includes both reservation for Scheduled
Castes and OB sees all the turbinado it
exceeds that and the Supreme Court will
not I don't think pronounce on a
petition challenging Tamil Nadu's
exceeding 50% anytime soon because I
think it fears the political
consequences of ruling one way or the
other
I just want to make a couple of points I
think which which will bring the
discussion back to both contemporary
politics and perhaps link it back up to
embedded America was a powerful
emancipatory figure and a very
interesting political strategist and I
think one of the interesting questions
to ask about cast in contemporary
politics is what has the regime of
reservation as we now know it done to
the narrative that Ambedkar in a sense
was trying to bring forth about modern
India and that now that have it sort of
two components one was in a sense the
component relating specifically to what
we now call Dalits
vitamin in a sense articulating their
historical marginalization in an
absolutely extraordinary way thinking
about instruments to overcome it but
also at the same time marrying the
project of the late emancipation to a
much broader constitutional vision that
is broad broadly liberal
constitutionalist so it's not just
equality this freedom I mean I mean it's
it's both sides it's not just the the
special privileges it's all the standard
liberal articles of the Indian
Constitution now I think what's
happening right now in the discourse of
caste in India is both those elements
are in the danger of being lost and one
way of thinking about this is the
following way this refers back to
innocence president Bollinger's account
that what is important is to try and
understand and have some clarity over
what the narrative about affirmative
action is and you can think of seven
different objectives that affirmative
action might perform firstly it's simply
an instrument for non-discrimination
very low baseline it's a form of
compensatory discrimination compensates
for past injustice --is it's a mode of
integration which is still different it
is simply a mode of empowerment you
could actually have lots of empowerment
and lots of discrimination at the same
time it is about diversity for
diversity's sake or it could be about a
particular view of what counts as the
legitimacy of institutions in societies
and this you might call broadly a mirror
theory of representation that India is
not a collection of individuals it's a
confederation of castes any system is
legitimate only if it mirrors that
Confederation of cause now these are all
very different narratives they overlap
in some cases and I think the consensus
was that in the case of Dalits by the
overlap was so great both in terms of
the the the the polling degree of
historical marginalization had
experienced but it really didn't matter
what justification you gave me the point
was something needed to be done I think
the introduction of other backward
castes into the narrative of as it were
compensated discrimination and
particularly post Mandela one of its
biggest casualties has been that is is -
is in a sense there is no clear shared
constitutional understanding now and the
court has not clarified it of what is
this regime of reservation supposed to
be about and if you don't have that
shared understanding then it is much
harder to design instruments and
targeting mechanisms so if you ask the
question of any reservation
why are you targeting somebody I think
there was consensus at least at least in
the case of Dalits who needs to be
targeted right so so your view of the
creamy layer whether the Timmy layer
should be excluded depends on whether or
not you think for example the Miller
theory of representation is really what
you are looking for in a political
system if you actually buy that
narrative then there's absolutely no
reason to exclude the demeanor so I
think we are at that juncture where the
reality the institutional reality of
reservations is very widely entrenched
along the dimensions that Mark Allender
sketched out and and unlikely to be
overturned I mean it's absolutely stone
even the CPM supports all of this and
sort of you know but I think what is
being lost in the process is I think a
clarity about a shared understanding
about what this narrative is supposed to
be about which is then leading to an
immense confusion if you like in a
politics of resentment around why are
particular groups with targeting not
others that that's that's in a sense the
first first point and and I think I
think one of the good things about the
American courts even when they've sort
of decided gone the wrong way from a
normative point of view is that I think
at least they constantly force this
question right what is this about it is
about diversity is about discrimination
and so the second thing I think that has
happened is the political as it were
confusion between other backward castes
and Dalits so a narrative a special
narrative about the place they had in
Indian society which belonged to the
dallas/fort for for overwhelming
historical reasons has if you like been
hijacked by all other kinds of groups
and even though the Supreme Court at the
margin tries to make a distinction
between them in some senses the politics
of a firm reservation right has now in a
sense become much too much associated
with the politics of basically assertion
and empowerment of any group so so who
deserves reservation practically anybody
who can actually claim that assertion
politically right I mean that's that's
in the sense that right and I think what
that has done is that that has closed
off some very deep questions that need
to be asked about the question of the
listening Abdallah to me so what are the
casualties of the reservation discourse
in India and Indian institutions is we
have now no language of thinking about
discrimination precisely because we have
granted reservation right I mean so you
know in some senses it's it's it's it's
right the second thing it has done and
and there I think the contrast with the
u.s. is striking that insofar as the US
has had some success
I think the institutional discourse was
meant to move along with and did manage
to move what you might call the ethical
discourse around diversity and reserve
in reservation right so that if you
wanted an integrated society it's not
simply a question of what social
resources the state hands out to
different groups it is fundamentally a
question about how citizens relate to
each other in interpersonal settings do
you eat with them on the same table you
know do you eat with African Americans
on the same table and so on and so forth
ironically in modern India I think
there's this period from roughly about
the 1920s to 1950 60s which is in its
own limited way is an articulation of
that ethical requirement I mean which we
now kind of dismiss condescendingly you
know Swami chicken and you know Gandhi
all of that we're fundamentally they see
this problem as a problem of this
ethical relationship I think what
institutionalize reservation has in
essence paradoxically done is air there
is no social movement articulating that
ethical requirement right so in fact in
the very same institutions and the very
same people who in a sense express their
progressive credentials right by
hitching their mass to the system
accomplish compensatory discrimination
are actually the sense least interested
not only not least interested arguably
in some cases sort of all was supposed
to all the ethical requirements that
would actually take to move society
native
dimension so we need to ask this
interesting question which Ambedkar was
always I mean I mean one of the nice
things about Ambedkar he's such an
amazing model psychologist to power
right is what is it that the system of
reservations has done to in a sense the
ethical thinking we have about the
relationship between citizens right has
it actually enhanced it in the removed
it in the right direction or has it in a
sense been ethics and the cheap if you
like and I suspect a lot of the
political consensus around it including
amongst ringleaders of you know various
political parties is that this is
emancipation emancipation on the cheap
right which is you have reservations
what else do you need so this is
producing a profound I think miss
recognition of what it will take to move
in there towards a genuinely integrated
society of equality a profound miss
recognition both of the material
conditions of that movement investment
in education all the all the busing
stuff all the hard work that needs to be
done base up right but also a miss
recognition in the sense of the kinds of
ethical relationships that he'll have to
be created in institutions for this
movement to be made made you know made
made possible and I think this miss
recognition at both levels has this
strange consequence of I think widening
the trust deficit within Indian society
so there is a legitimate complaint
whenever you talk about opening up this
conversation you know look let's invest
more in education why aren't you know
why aren't politicians getting more
agitated about the quality of our
institutions which will actually have a
much more meaningful impact on the lives
of those they want to empower than
others is that in this context where
there is a trust deficit about the
ability of the state to in short order
address those material conditions where
you don't have political movements and
reform movements that are addressing the
ethical questions around integration
reservation is the sort of is this kind
of default position that everybody
converges to well there's nothing else
going on so let's have and so I suspect
and this the thought I will produce
which is that I think it's going to take
even longer in some sense I mean unless
those material conditions improve
substantially you know there's some
movement in that direction I think I I
do think we are beginning we will see a
qualitative change in in primary
education I think in five to ten years I
do think the curve is turning on that
unless those material preconditions are
addressed
I think reservation is going to be this
complicated sort of amalgam of
all these different objectives that I
talked about and you're unlikely to get
clarity on the basic questions of who
are you targeting why you're targeting
them how are you targeting them what are
the objectives of targeting them and the
last and final just the closing thought
which is that I do think a medgar's
normative vision was that there should
be these forms of compensatory
discrimination as instruments for
empowerment but his fundamental vision
of Indian constitutionalism was also the
other articles this is not this is a
constitution about individual freedom
this is a constitution whose normative
vision is to emancipate people from
compulsory identities and the
interesting and now again emancipating
people from compulsory identities is a
complicated social process endogamy will
have to break down again all the
material conditions for social mixing
will have to be created but I think the
danger in contemporary India is that
that emancipatory vision of a society
free of those kinds of compulsory
identities is also in the danger of
being obscured by the way we have
thought of these compensatory
discrimination policies
you